[Music]
seth is with us seth's in los angeles hi
seth welcome to the ramsey show
hi hey how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
yeah let me just first off you know
start by saying that i really appreciate
you know all the information i've been
able to gain um just from watching your
videos from the past couple of weeks and
i've been uh you really do give an
inspiring um
stance when it comes to finances and
stuff and you know as embarrassing as
my situation is or i feel like it is um
i thought that you would be the best
person to help in this regard
thank you basically what what i've been
going through is um and just give you a
little bit of background um i'm the only
one who works in my household um it's me
and my wife newly married uh we just had
our one year anniversary on sunday um
and basically what i have is a
auto loan um you know one of our biggest
bills
um
that's just causing me a lot of headache
i've had it you know previously
before i got engaged and i got married
and you know as a single person um this
car was you know just right for me it
was something i liked it was you know
i'll be honest it was a little bit fancy
or at least flashy in my opinion i
i really do enjoy the car but as of now
being married and a little bit more
mature the the the car itself um and
just everything that's bringing with it
isn't something that i can maintain
anymore so my question is you know is it
is it a good idea to kind of give the
car up or is that just something i'm
kind of rushing into just as a last
minute option or
i need some information on that kind of
by give it up do you mean a voluntary
repossession
yeah exactly how much do you owe on the
car
uh so as of now um i called in and i
owed 22 like roughly around 22 000 for
the car have you looked up what it's
worth
yeah um i looked up was worth um uh just
recently this weekend we took it over to
a couple of places carmax toyota just a
couple other places just to try to get
um
you know a sense of what people or what
they would give us for the the car um
and so right now the consensus is that
you know 13 000 is you know
the amount that people would give just
because of all the problems it has with
it as a check engine light
um and i mean you know it's it's an audi
so it's a really nice car but it's
luxury and
you know the parts are expensive how old
are you
24.
okay
um
well the car market is unbelievably hot
right now
did you have a car before that you owed
more on than it was worth that you were
upside down and you rolled the negative
equity into this deal
um i did uh but it was under my parents
name um but you rolled negative equity
into this
deal no no no no and with this deal so
this car
what year is this car
it's a 2015.
okay and would you pay for
it oh
i was a while ago i believe i out the
door it was like 26 to 28 somewhere like
that how do you still i'm not buying the
13. the 13 is a bad number yeah you're
getting snookered
yeah
yeah i feel i feel the same way honestly
when i took it to carmax you know they
just said it had because of the engine
light um as a dangerous scratch you know
towards the towards the rear of it as
well and
um you know there are some some
underlying problems with it i guess that
they
had inspected and that's the number that
they came and gave me and from
underlying problems or what
um well so so far from what i know um
when i start the car it starts to you
know stutter and stuff like that and i i
recently had to replace you know what
are you making work on my car
i make roughly
i make like 4 100 gross
do you have a baby
no no why's your wife not work
uh she got hurt a couple years back um
and that's a whole another situation but
basically her
her right shoulder is you know a bit of
a
a bit of a nuisance to her and it's
constantly coming out of the socket
it's a long story but she's basically
unable to
to work her job
well a physical job probably but she
could get a job
oh no 100 and i mean that that is
something that i because you guys need
money
so okay yeah here's what's going on okay
um you're looking
and it's human nature and i do it too so
i'm not picking on you but you're
looking for the easy way out and the
voluntary repo is not the easy way out
and 13k is absurd on this car there's
something wrong with this story
so what i would do is take it to a
mechanic and pay to have it fixed and if
that costs you 500 bucks good spend the
500 bucks get it fixed get the check
engine light off get the stuttering
going away then all you got to scratch
and then the car suddenly magically
going to be worth 20.
and then you're 2 000 in the hole you go
down the credit union you borrow the 2
000 and you sell the car
yeah because if they take this car and
sell it they're gonna sell it for eight
thousand dollars on the repo lot and
they're gonna sue you for the difference
in twenty two and eight
known as fourteen
you lose control of the price when you
give it to them
that it sells for therefore you are
going to dramatically increase the
amount you owe
that you're in the hole
so what i'm trying to do here is to work
you out of this hole
i i mean you might even be able to sell
it for what you owe on it if you fix it
go get it fixed and sell it
but don't give it back to them because
you give it back to them you're gonna
have a 14 000 lawsuit on your hands
where they come after you and sue you
for the difference on this and then
you're gonna be calling me up how do i
settle a deficit on a car repo
and you got a car repo on your credit
and your wife needs to go get a job
so that we've got money to fix all this
stuff
and i want to tell you your entire
disposition it may just be how you roll
through life just kind of a low-key guy
as dave said it sounds like you're
looking for
what's the least painful way to get out
of debt like kind of thinking about this
and maybe if i just
you gotta run dude
you gotta say we're done with this life
and we're gonna be finished with it and
okay i can't work on my shoulder i'm
gonna get a job with health insurance so
i can have surgery i'm gonna get a job
selling stuff from home i we're gonna
we're gonna have to fix this thing
and it sounds like you'll have some
marriage challenges just
that's a whole other conversation you
said it says you've got some mental
health stuff going on so physical stuff
kind of it's all this well you know
it's just gonna be this way next month
and the month after that and the month
after that until somebody says no more
seth there's an old book called the
seven habits of highly effective people
that was a perennial bestseller it was a
bestseller month after month year after
year after year by stephen covey
the seven habits
of highly effective people
habit number one
they are proactive
they happen to things
instead of things happening to them
and that's what john's describing for
you
that you you need to get in that mode
where i'm going to happen to this car
thing i'm going to happen to these
things there are situ there's things
here you can control
and if you control the controllables
you're gonna end up with a better life
real fast too
yeah like it after it yesterday right
now get after it
light it on fire baby let's let's just
see it burn
not the car
your life
[Laughter]
don't burn the car stephen that's not
what i said
this is the ramsey show